Salve il gioco che voglio recensire oggi
è et L'extraterrestre per Atari 2600
quello che mi ha incuriosito di questo
gioco È che tutte le riviste e tutti i
siti internet lo considerano il gioco
peggiore nella storia dei videogiochi E
come c'è scritto su Wikipedia da cui
Cito testualmente è considerato uno dei
videogiochi peggiori di tutti i tempi e
uno dei più grandi flop commerciali
della storia dei videogiochi c'è scritto
anche che fu uno dei fattori che causò
il fallimento della tari e simboleggia
l'intera crisi dei videogiochi del
1983 Wow Beh allora proviamolo con le
nostre
[Musica]
[Applauso]
maniok
Ok fin da subito non è chiaro che cavolo
bisogna fare in questo dannato gioco si
comanda t e si va in giro per i vari
scenari a trovare da quello che ho letto
su Wikipedia pezzi del telefono per
telefonare a casa Beh tutto qui il
problema è che quei pezzi del telefono
non sembrano pezzi del telefono va bene
che era stato progettato questo gioco
sull latari 2600 e la grafica è quella
che Ma scusate vi sembrano pezzi del
telefono questo senza una spiegazione
uno come cavolo fa a capirlo è come se
non bastasse Ci sono due tipi di Nemici
che rompono le palle dall'inizio alla
fine gli agenti dell FBI Ehi Lasciami
lasciami e quegli noiosi scienziati che
tentano di portarvi nel loro laboratorio
Lasciami
lasciami ma il nemico principale non è
nessuno dei due sono quelle dannatissima
buche che si trovano in ogni singolo
scenario e Dio vi Salvi se ci Cadete
dentro Vai su vai su Vai su vai su vai
su no Ma come ho fatto dai Vai su vai su
vai su Vai su vai su Vai su vai su Dai
porca Ma cos'è sta cosa un problema del
gioco un Glitch Che cos'è Oh Finalmente
ce l'ho fatta Vediamo se riesco a
trovare altri pezzi
del
[Musica]
lo devo
finire
[Musica]
V